[موسيقى]
هذا ما تحلم به اسرائيل جذب يهودي العالم
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه وقد حشدت في سبيل
ذلك قادت الراي والفكر ووسائل اعلامها
التي اظهرت من حين الى اخر صورا ومقاطعا
للمهاجرين تاره من متن السفن واخرى على
سلالم الطائرات ملوحين بالاعلام ومده لهم
البسط الحمراء حتى يمر فوقها مبتهجين على
وقع الاناشيد ولكن لم يكد يمر عامان على
انشاء الكيان حتى بدات الهجره العكسيه وما
زالت هذه المشكله تستمر وتتفاقم وتقض
مضاجع القياده رغم الجهود الكبيره التي
بذلتها الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه في
تشجيع الهجرات اليهوديه واصدار العوده عام
1950 الذي يعطي كل يهوديا في العالم الحق
في استيطان فلسطين والحصول على الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه بزعم ان اسرائيل وطن قومي
لليهود
[موسيقى]
بدات الهجره من اسرائيل في نهايه
اربعينيات القرن الماضي حين غادر عشره
بالمئه من الوافدين بين عامي
وهو ما دفع الحكومه انذاك الى سن قيود
صارمه بفرض تاشيره خروج كثيره ما كان يرفض
منحها
لكن على الرغم من تلك القيود بلغ عدد
الذين غادروا اسرائيل عند حلول الذكرى
العاشره لانشائها عام
1958 نحو 100 الف مهاجر وخرابه 180 الفا
بحلول عام
1967 قبل ان ينخفض انخفاضا حادا خلال
السبعينيات ليعود وينشط تدريجيا بمرور
الوقت حتى بلغ عدد المهاجرين بحلول عام
2020 نحو
756 الف شخص ووصل في عام 2022 الى نحو 900
الف فهل توقف الامر عند هذا الحد وفق
استطلاع للراي اجرته القناه الثالثه عشره
الاسرائيليه فان ثم 28% من الاسرائيليين
ما زالوا يفكرون في الهجره كثير منهم
لديهم جوازات سفر اجنبيه اخرى وهؤلاء يرون
ان نمط العيش في تلك البلدان افضل حالا من
اسرائيل في اكثر من مناسبه فاق عدد
المهاجرين من اسرائيل عدد القادمين اليها
وخصوصا في المده بين انتفاضه الحجاره عام
1987 وانتفاضه الاقصى عام 2000 ففي عام
2011 بلغ عدد القادمين الى الاراضي
المحتله 21 الفا في حين تجاوز عدد
المهاجرين منها سبعه وعشرين الف يهودي ما
الاسباب التي تدفع اليهود الى مغادره
اسرائيل ياتي في مقدمه الاسباب الشعور
بعدم الامان بسبب المخاوف الامنيه ومن اهم
الاسباب ايضا تخوف العلمانيين من التحولات
الديموغرافيه والايبيولوجيه المتمثله في
ازدياد نسبه الحاردين المتدينين ثم تاتي
مشكلات الاسكان والاقتصاد وصعوبه الاندماج
في مجتمع تدعي اسرائيل انه مترابط جدا
[موسيقى]
تمنع ظهور العدو وان تاثير المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في دفع الاسرائيليين الى
الهجره الى خارج فلسطين تقول كورد افيتال
الرئيس السابقه للجنه استيعاب المهاجرين
لاول مره في تاريخ الصراع اثبت
الفلسطينيون للاسرائيليين ان الاحتلال
مكلف الى درجه انهم دون اسلحه متطوره
وحديثه خلقوا ميزان رعب للصراع
وان ضرباتنا ستكون حاضره متى عدتم للعدوان